-Welcome, welcome
back to the show.
What a week you've had, huh?
-Oh, man.
-Has it been emotional?
-Yeah. It's been a little bit
of every emotion
that's inside of my body.
Emotions I didn't know I had,
they've been coming out.
Yeah.
But in silence, though.
I've been keeping it together.
-Yeah, exactly.
You've gotten so much love
on Twitter.
I saw that Barack Obama
tweeted at you.
-Yeah.
-How does that make you feel?
I mean, do you think back
of when you were a kid
and be like, "I can't believe
the president --
a president
is gonna tweet at me"?
A tweet, you wouldn't even know
what that is, yeah, I guess.
-I'm at my final game in Miami,
and they had all these tributes
to me.
And the first one that comes up
when the game started
is Barack Obama.
And it wasn't just
a "Congratulations, Dwyane"
message.
It was a long message.
I was like,
"He really took time."
-He took some time to give
a real thing for you.
It's just amazing,
but I was like --
I think about, you know,
everyone's career
when you're first starting out,
and you're in high school,
and you don't even know
if you're gonna make it.
-Especially me.
I know I do.
-Yeah, well, you kind of did
a little bit,
because I found this.
This is a --
This was in the local paper
when you were in high school.
That's you, right?
-Yeah.
-And this is your quote.
It said, "I see myself
retiring from the NBA
to spend time
with my wife and kids,
also retiring as one of
the greatest to play the game."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-Positive.
Hey, speak it into existence.
-I mean...
you're kind of doing that.
-So, the crazy thing about that
is, at that time,
I was 17 years old.
That was 1999.
So today as I sit here,
it's obviously 2019.
I'm 37 years old.
It was actually
20 years ago exactly.
So it's crazy.
-To the day.
That's -- Does it feel good
going out on your terms?
-You know, it does.
You know, in this sport
and sports, period --
well, in any career --
sometimes, you know,
they might push you out
a little bit,
give you a little nudge,
you know, when it's time.
But for me to be able to,
you know, come to this decision
and say that this is
the time for me
and to be able to have
the season that I had
where everybody like,
"You got another year,
you got another two years,"
that was exactly what
I wanted everybody saying,
instead of, like --
You know, I told Coach this.
I never wanted my coach
to be like --
to look past me on the bench,
you know?
You know, like --
-"Oh, yeah, you're here, too."
-Yeah, like, "Aw, man,
we got to put somebody in."
-"We got to throw him a bone."
-Yeah. So before that,
I was like, "Yo, I'm out."
-You never want
to experience that.
On your last home game,
you fell into the crowd
after doing a fadeaway shot.
And you fell into two of the
most famous people on earth --
John Legend and Chrissy Teigen.
And this is one
of the best photos.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ] Look at John's --
Look at John's face.
Look at his face.
-For all the kids out there.
-Yeah.
-Look at the focus, okay?
I ain't worried about nothing.
I am focused.
Look at the follow-through.
-There's beer in the air.
-Luckily --
I'll say this for John.
Lucky that we're friends,
first of all.
You know,
lucky that we're friends.
But I do owe them some vodka
and all that that was spilled.
-Whatever was spilled out there,
yeah.
-Whatever spilled on my back,
I owe that to them.
-So you didn't do that
on purpose, right?
-I didn't do that on purpose.
I had shot, like, you know,
a little fadeaway shot
in that corner.
And the ball had --
It went in and out,
so I was really focused
and looking.
And when I turned around,
I seen who it was,
and I was like,
"Oh, my goodness."
I couldn't believe it was them.
-Now it's a meme, but it's
perfect in your last game.
-So, my wife --
You see my wife over there.
She's, like, grabbing me
but looking at the rim
at the same time.
-Is that her there?
-Yeah.
She's still looking
at the shot, too.
-[ Laughs ]
She's focused, too!
-You see her?
-She's just as focused. See?
-We're focused.
-That's why --
That's what a real --
couple goals.
Goals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's next?
I know you're a businessman,
an entrepreneur, as well,
but, I mean, do we know?
-Well, getting over
this hangover is what's next.
I've never been hungover before.
I'm 37.
This is my first hangover,
and it sucks.
I'm pulling it together
right now,
but inside, I am sweating
underneath here.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, it's terrible.
-You celebrated last night?
-I've been celebrating
and celebrating and celebrating.
I still got my game shoes on,
I've been celebrating so much.
I didn't even take them off.
-I'm honored to be
your first hangover.
This is an honor for me.
I just want to thank you
on behalf of all your fans
for everything you've done.
And whatever is next, come back
on the show and talk about it.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
-Congratulations.
-We love you, dude.
-Thank you.
-Dwyane Wade, everybody!